all right well good morning and welcome
to the simons institute
my name is peter bartlett i'm the
associate director here very happy to
see you all here we're a collaborative
research institute focused on
theoretical computer science
and its connections to other areas of
science and technology and society and
of course uh statistics and data science
have become hugely important in all
areas of of our lives uh and and also in
computer science and we're seeing this
increased uh emphasis on on topics that
touch on statistics touch on data
science you know in the collaborative
research programs that we run
here at the institute um and you know of
course very
uh very happy to be hosting this
workshop this week um
uh on uh statistics and um
uh remind me what was the what was the
title
statistics and its role in the big data
era right
that was not it
um and and very happy to be celebrating
the occasion of two years after peter's
peter bickle's 80th birthday
um we've been making
you know many attempts to to make this
this workshop happen so thrilled that it
could finally happen in in person um a
big thank you to the organizers hyun
hwang elisa lavina peter bulman uh
ponding
junkin found uh katarina chris and uh
yankee rittov uh and also a big thank
you to uh she's just stepped out
um ashley hassan has been
has done a
great job with all the local
arrangements um so big thanks to all
those folks
[Music]
and just a couple of quick words uh on
logistics before i hand over to to lisa
so um at lunchtime you can leave your
stuff in lockers on the far side of the
building they operate with a pin code so
um uh you know that should be more
convenient for many for many of you and
um
for speakers our videographer here i
mean far is going to be helping with
computers and uh uh microphones
all right
oh oh and today thank you um
i'll forget everything if it's not
written down you see that um today is
the
the first wednesday of the month and so
at 12 o'clock there'll be a siren
that'll slowly build up and a voice that
will say this is a test it is just a
test
so so relax uh and and whoever's the
speaker who's supposed to finish at 12
you know you get a special warning
thank you peter
well welcome everyone to this workshop
uh it's hard to believe it's finally
happening
um
i was trying to remember when we started
planning it
um i couldn't actually find the oldest
email but um i know i created the folder
for this conference in july 2018.
so it's been four years and initially
looked like a very easy conference to
organize because anybody you ask
you say i'm organizing a conference for
peter beck's birthday would you like to
come and they say yes immediately
um so that's been great and then it was
planned for may 2020 originally so we're
finally happening i'd just like to thank
um a few people first of all i need to
thank peter himself for letting me do
this
he was slightly reluctant but he agreed
um and also nancy who has been very
supportive like to thank my
co-organizers um peter and the staff at
the simons institute ashley and kulani
who have been very helpful
also judy macdonald my assistant who's
done a lot of work and i think you all
have gotten emails from her and the
berkeley staff
and all the speakers and all of you who
are finally here today in person and
i'll hand over to the current chair of
the berkeley statistics department in
dream dude
thank you very much lisa and thank you
to all the organizers for putting
together this conference
and good morning everyone
so my first encounter with peter vickel
was
30 something years ago
as an undergraduate student through a
book
that's often simply refers to as bitcoin
docsup
my second encounter was through a letter
my letter of admission to the phd
program at berkeley
which was signed by peter who was then
the department chair
and then my third encounter was through
a door in evans hall that had peter's
name on it
what the starstruck phd student
eventually discovered was that behind
these seminal books
and these doors bearing illustrious
names pickle
blackwell freeman
freeman layman
to name only a few
we're wonderful teachers
scholars colleagues
and friends
peter is part of a distinguished lineage
of statisticians who have shaped
and continued to shape our discipline
his secondary grandfather is none other
than jersey neyman
the founder of our department
and also one of the founding fathers of
modern statistics
his academic father is eric layman
peter received his ph.d from berkeley in
1963
with a dissertation on asymptotically
non-parametric statistical inference in
the multivariate case
according to the math genealogy project
he has 61
children
700
744
descendants
and that doesn't even include their
young researchers he is mentored
his numerous children continue to push
the boundaries of statistics and data
science at academic institutions and
companies around the world
and many of them are here today at the
workshop including the workshop
organizers
so peter's contribution has spanned the
breadth of our discipline in areas that
include asymptotic theory
semi-parametric models
the bootstrap hidden markov models
he has recently been working on
statistical methods for genomic data
analysis and has been a wonderful mentor
to one of my postdocs
i never cease to be amazed by peter's
energy
curiosity and passion for learning and
understanding
his commitment to the department and to
the university is exceptional
it's been a pleasure and privilege to
know him first as a student
and then
as a colleague
so i'm delighted that we have the
occasion to celebrate peter this week
the diversity of talks on the conference
program is a testimony to peter's broad
scientific reach
and the audience gathered here today
also reflects the friendships he has
developed with so many
and now among the persons who have known
peter for several decades
i'm delighted to introduce jennifer
chase
who is the associate provost for the new
division of computing data science and
society
dean of the school of information and
professor of statistics
electrical engineering computer sciences
and mathematics
thanks so much sandrine and good morning
to everyone it is really uh
wonderful to see you all here and i
assume there are many more of you
online
to to celebrate peter with us
uh the
topic of the workshop statistics in the
big data era
uh
is
to a large extent due to peter himself
in all of the
you know with with all of his
students and his
descendants
as as we just heard
uh the topic is near and dear
to
my heart
at the as we form the division of
computing data science and society
at berkeley
we are on our way to becoming the first
new college at berkeley in over half a
century
and this is of course um
due in large part
to the
legacy
of peter others i'm seeing here i'm
seeing ben i'm seeing so many people
uh
you know peter has really
helped to
shape
the direction that statistics has taken
at berkeley
and is fundamental to what we are
building here the workshop provides a
natural opportunity to celebrate peter's
80th birthday as we heard a couple of
years late
he's long been one of the world's
leading statisticians
and to name a few areas in which he has
pioneered research
adaptive estimation
asymptotic theory
computational biology
decision theory
machine learning
resampling methods
and semi and non-parametric modeling and
i'm sure i've missed
many
many other topics congratulations peter
for making such significant
contributions
to your own field of statistics and far
beyond
uh
i i believe i first met peter 15 or 20
years ago
we were both members of what was what is
now known
as the board of mathematical sciences
and analytics bmsa
of the national academies
uh i recall that peter first joined
um ex-officio
because he was chair of cats which was
the committee on statistics
for the national academies
he then
became
chair
of the bms which was
as we were just talking about and an
unusual choice
i think
the national academies realized
that they needed a strong
leader
to
to help move the board of mathematical
sciences
more towards
applications uh
during my tenure there with peter as our
fearless leader and he reminded me also
uh uh
margaret wright
and peter and i were really um
were
really strong advocates to change the
name
of the board of mathematical sciences to
put an a at the end the a was originally
for applications it's now been changed
to analytics
so yes i hadn't even known that either
peter and i saw him shaking his head no
you know things changed but they kept
the the acronym
um i'm sure you can imagine it was not
an easy
change
for this preeminent
national mathematics board
but peter really helped everyone to
understand
that mathematics needed to embrace the
full range of applications
here we are today discussing this range
of applications and analytics
afforded by math and statistics
especially in this new era of rapidly
increasingly large data sets
and i'm delighted that we're doing this
in peter's honor
i i know that
all of you
as peter are deeply invested in
strengthening core statistical theory
and methods along with applications of
statistics to problems in a range of
domain specific areas from genomics to
social networks
working on core issues in mathematics
and statistics even in the absence of
real-world applications is absolutely
thrilling
indeed
peter has spent much of his career doing
this
as have i
i think we are both enamored of the
beauty of mathematics and statistics
but developing and applying new
statistical methods to pressing societal
changes
from misinformation and bias to
biomedicine and human health
to climate change and sustainability
to human welfare and social justice
has become increasingly important as the
world looks to statisticians to find
approaches
and solutions to the urgent problems of
our time
we need a human-centered approach to
statistics so that we can better
frame the perspective and purpose and
anticipate
the problems
but we also need tremendous innovation
in the core of statistics to move our
work dramatically forward addressing the
most difficult technical challenges and
realizing the greatest opportunities
together with peter as our example
we can lead the way in developing
solutions to these challenges and in
educating the next generation to carry
this mission into the future
thank you and happy belated birthday
[Applause]
i unfortunately have to take off
oh
oh